foreign
[Music]
guys you can now finally relax because
the clear gods have been caught what do
you mean the clear Gods what's the clear
gun wait clear like at the airport no
that's what I was thinking this is a
this is a gang of criminals that called
themselves the clear Gods oh yeah no one
was aware of until right now can we
guess what they do because we're gonna
go visible they got caught what do you
think they did you use the hand give us
something close
I'm gonna say Matt okay the name clear
Gods has to do with the crime they were
commef not math not even drugs Scotch
tape not even
like yeah you can see Invisalign yeah
yeah we know you have
a beautiful anybody
no I love it so I guess like in criminal
terms the the
um the word clear it's it's basically a
term that means like you you faked a
line of credit or something oh I thought
it was Scientology clearing oh you
thought it was that oh well wait I've
heard of this they're selling fake
e-meters you uh
you get really good credit right and
then you get a [ __ ] ton of cards or
whatever and then just don't pay pretty
much yeah wow but the way that they did
it so they're they're a detroit-based
criminal organization of seven people at
least they think it's seven they
probably are more but they caught seven
of them and here's exactly what they did
they would buy stolen identification
from like black market or whatever or
like a dark web you know you just buy
people's IDs yeah so they steal those
IDs they feed the data to corrupt at T
employees that they knew that worked in
the stores they're all corrupt by the
way all 18 employees they're all
especially the cable ones dude let me
tell you about those [ __ ] they
love going like oh yeah yeah we
understand your problem we're gonna go
talk to my manager in the back they go
talk in the back for like 40 minutes and
you're just sitting there waiting they
they [ __ ] you know they stop they're
getting off on it they're jerking off
back there thinking about you waiting
they're watching the cameras like oh
wait till I get this he's got his hands
on his hips
and then a manager comes out and then
they're like talking to you like oh yeah
let me actually let me talk to somebody
else can you get clearance we'll fix
this for you and then they go back in
again for another 40 minutes and then
you're just sitting out there and they
just keep doing that with 18 other
managers same guys and every dealership
yeah and everyone's on a [ __ ] break
dude oh I can't help you that so that's
what I mean by ATT people are all that's
why you should switch to Spectrum yeah
get forget forget the clear God let them
free arrest everyone at ATT dude all
right we moved on for this so yeah they
get the another Nick take here's the
elements the stolen identification mixed
with the corrupt ATT employees and then
what they do is they uh they'll say
they'll do a fake phone plan they'll add
all these users that don't really exist
because the ATT guys okay cool yeah see
Crooks dude and then what they're gonna
do is they're gonna clear the credit
line so that they can buy iPhones on
pure credit and they would just buy a
shitload of iPhones and they would do
this over and over and they would sell
the iPhones like um black market or
Craigslist or whatever they did it to
the point where it cost 28 million in
loss holy [ __ ] I think the real that's a
lot of iPhones which is also going to be
inflated if that's coming from the
company saying they lost it right but
even 10 million worth of iPhones that's
so many iPhones you guys but it's not
just with seven guys it's not just the
price of the phone it's also the the
price of reparations for all the
people's identities because all the real
people so those people are having their
credit lines totally decimated and then
you know how much time it takes away I
don't know if you guys have ever
identity theft freaking long ass time to
like get everything you deal with fraud
the real [ __ ] criminals and I hate to
do this again
no but it's 18 employees without
without them the racket wouldn't go up
you're right you're right once again
Crux dude
ATT employees I'll interview you for the
video yeah yeah why at T shouldn't exist
well they all should die the weird thing
is like that started like because what I
used to work at what now has become uh
what the [ __ ] you used to work with what
now has become T-Mobile I used to do
that job in the morning what was it
before Motorola Mobile well mobile
Telesis was like the it used to be that
and that's where the tea came from yeah
a bunch of them combined yeah
and then uh they just flipped it there
was always a corrupt employee like we
just knew who they were and they were
like doing what's the characteristic of
a corrupt he's wearing an ATT shirt
thank you one of the Dead giveaways is
back then it was easy to tell because uh
this is like 2001 and you only made
money if you sold phones if you don't
sell anything you could go two weeks
with zero on your paycheck oh wow so
we're not selling yeah they don't do
that anymore there's no wages or
whatever no wages it was all sales so
the mall kiosk shark dudes ought to be
like hey you got a phone come here let
me sign you up that's why they're so
desperate is because it's all commission
based so the thing is you can always
sort of tell who was uh who was corrupt
because they just weren't selling real
phones not a lot of people are going to
keep that job after getting that many
zeros right but if they're doing
something on the side when they're
getting a cash subsidy then yeah they're
gonna stay there you know so we were
always like what the practice dude's in
a good mood and he hasn't sold in months
there's this one cat in our high school
he used to work on the work at the vans
in Alhambra and then so all his homies
always got hooked up with like they have
the like their whole Squad had like the
freshest Vans and then I think they end
up finding out I don't know how many
pairs that he would uh
I think it was like 30 pairs a week or
something that he was just like somehow
washing them and they ended up getting
arrested or whatever but he's watching
them
as much as a high school that could I
was like Danny ocean huh Danny ocean
over here maybe he's washing 30 pairs of
[ __ ] sneakers
it's crazy how easy it is to be a
corrupt self cell phone like because the
access that we had back then I could
look up personal info on like anybody
like as long as I got your name like
written down you know like you can see
the someone's whole family's numbers and
addresses like very easily so when you
think of the the extent of access and
even back then you could even buy them
now like those lead generators you could
just buy them now and they'll give you
like a hundred thousand emails and then
you have a ton of information on lead
generators if I if I go rob a Payless
right now and then I just take those
shoes and sell them to somebody Bart's
like damn she's washing some shoes
dude high level that's how innocent I am
[ __ ] that's a heist that's a [ __ ]
crazy
when ATT started becoming like the the
more low-life one of out of all of them
it used to be sick when it was landline
[ __ ] it was like oh I have 18. my
favorite thing is Nick doesn't even hate
that ATT higher-ups he hates the
employees
[Laughter]
sometime I had to go Bunch with uh with
my
labor [ __ ] with her bill and I just
like kept going back and I kept icing
this out so it was just so you still
believe in the establishment you just
hate the feelings the people that work
am I my one very small experience makes
me hate all 18 teams okay get them well
isn't ATT the like the way that they
were able to hack Barack Obama's Twitter
see criminals didn't they do it that way
dude like ATT is the most LAX about like
are you that guy okay here's the info
I'm that guy I'm Obama
yes I am why yes I am that's a good oh
one of our buddies that's a cop he says
uh the cell phone providers they're
political too so when they get like
let's say a a warrant and they need to
get uh people's like uh what is it like
when they get people's um like either
text transcripts or who they've been
calling or whatever as a cop the ones
that are leaning a certain way or
whatever will actually resist giving it
because he's not talking to he's talking
to corporate enough people to have the
records and he's like anytime like this
criminal if they're trying to get this
criminal and it's this company he's like
[ __ ] I know where their political
positions are and they're not going to
give it to me that's funny if you like
hey who are they I want to use them yeah
I don't know I'll tell you off camera
okay how funny if you activate an ATT
iPhone and it just comes with truth
social already built in there we go is
this political
yeah yeah remember when um what was it
like I this is a long time ago but I
think iPods they came like you couldn't
not have the [ __ ] the YouTube two
albums oh yeah everyone hated YouTube
for that came with YouTube everyone was
like [ __ ] YouTube man and every time
people plugged it in their car to get
directions the first song that would
come out was [ __ ] YouTube that was
the word press Shuffle and [ __ ]
YouTube what's YouTube's best song
they all suck no like because there's
one song that they're like mysterious
ways I don't know oh but was that his
Solo or I don't know anybody that
listens to you I think YouTube sucks
actually I think they only got big
because of the iPod thing yeah I know
it's probably the only reason but they
were famous before that yeah they were
but mostly because Sunny what's his name
right yeah Bono you two wrote Wonderwall
right no because it's sunny Bono it's
not [ __ ] I'm just asking dude I'm
just asking bro they sound the same to
me aren't they all British yeah British
I think dude you don't like it no I'm
are you sure that's Oasis dude I know he
didn't do that but it sounds the same I
thought he did wonder wall for a second
I was actually gonna give him a little
bit of credit yeah dude it's all the
same but who listens to them like our
parents I don't know anybody our parents
for sure dude that's a video nobody
actually listens to YouTube
conspiracy why is he still never seen
anyone actually listen to YouTube I've
never even heard a movie play a YouTube
song yeah never that's true Mark did
just a YouTube song